あああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちははじめまして春藤いうと申します
これから私はセックスそして性暴力の話をします
キャッシュバック等で少し級の悪くなる可能性がある方は少しの時間だけお酒を外し
ください
逆に下に話を持った方はぜひ聴いていただきたいと
思います
今日私が皆さんにお話ししたいのは今まである性に関する常識を壊して別に組織を
つくろうという話です
世の中にあるセックスについての誤った常識というのはこういうものです
男女が2人きりになって食事に聞い
酒を飲んで
それは
まあセックスで前段階であると
あるいは1戦家に行ったら
それはもう性行為をしている合図だとかそういうことですね
もちろん多くの人は食事をすることや家とセックスの入るとは呼びません
ムードとか
いい雰囲気といいますねもう一つ二人義理じゃないケースの
今の線維化するよしっていうのは
大人数だったらちょっとぐらいの上段は許されるというものです
例えばサークルとかそういうところでの大人数でもう一回今年は自粛している人が多い
かもしれません
そういう中でぶっちゃけうちのサークルで一番エロい女子って誰だと思う
あるいは1年生男子裸になってよそれでみんなにサーブのがウチのサークルの伝統だ
から
こういうことを言われるとですねちょっと暗い家でもノリ悪いって言われたら嫌だなぁ
とか雰囲気壊したらやだなーと思ってみましょうよ
言えない人多いと思うんですねこういう時でも出てくるのは法とか
ウインチとかそういう言葉なんですねで私が今日このスピーチを聞いた方に言いたい
ことは
もうそういう無理とか雰囲気とかそういう言葉で語られる性に関する常識
やめましょうそして新しい料-を作りましょう
そういうことを私は言いたいですだって食事院に行くことはセックスしていい会津じゃ
ありませんし
飲み会で突然誰かに性的な対象として見られたりとか
脱ぐことを強要されたり
とかそういうことをも嫌ですよねだから新しい方向へと変えていきたいわけです
そして私が提案する新しい常識というのはへい的同意
セクシャルコンセントです
今日みなさんに覚えて帰ってほしいのはこの一言です
同意のない性的言動はすべて性暴力である
これですこれ最後に繰り返しですがとりあえず最初にも言わせてください
a 知らなかった遠いとかそうじゃなくて楽しいか楽しくないかじゃないの
なんと思った方もいるかもしれません
そんなことを聞いたことないそう思う人もいるかもしれません
それもそのはずです学校ではなりませんもし学校で何か性教育というようなことを聞い
たことがあればそれは精子と卵子がどう出会うだとかあるいは
生完成症の種類とかそういうことですね
でも実際に性的なことというのは人と人がすることはどんどんですね
なので人とどうやってコミュニケーションを取るのかについてもらう必要が本当はたん
です
それなのに前についてはなぜか学的なことというんですかね生物学的なことがわかれば
あとはすべて往路系みたいな感じになってるんですがもうそれすらも正確に伝わってい
ないケースというのもあると思いますが
ただやはりコミュニケーションが重要だということが叶い無視されているようにもん
ですね
法とか雰囲気とか言葉にし
なくてもいいなっていうそういうことが一つの常識になっているように思います
大事なことは人と人はお互い傷つけず村中をしあってその先に楽しいとかそういうこと
があるんですね
このためには性的なことをセックスだけでなくキスやハグ
あるいは性的な言葉を相手に言うこと俺らをする前には必ず相手が納得し同意している
必要があります
これが遠いです
でもたん兄じゃあ x していい入っ
いう風に言っただけでも遠いになりませんどういう状況なら同意したと言えるの
でしょうか
どういう状況であればどうしたのかという考えるために同意できない状況とはどんな
状況なのかについて考えてみましょう
一つ目の同意できない状況は権力さがあるときです
例えば上司と部下で漁師から誘われたら中の方はどう思うでしょうか
音はったら仕事で不利益になるかもしれない
そう考えてもおかしくないはずですもちろん
同士のガーは仕事の事なんか一言も言ってません
前世な気持ちだというかも知れませんでもた子もの弱い人というのはそう考えますです
から
城主飛ぶ事か学校の先生と生徒とか
指導者と生徒とか先輩ところ
後半の間でもそうもしれません
あるいは親と子の間もそうですね同委は成立しません
なので同市と部下の間にもは生徒と先生の間でも真実の愛が芽生えるかもしれないじゃ
ないかという方いらっしゃるかもしれませんで私そういう形に言いたいんです
ぜひ真実の愛があるなら卒業するまで待ってください
前日の愛があるなら直属の部下ではなくて部署が変わるまでもあってください
えっそれが待ってないのならば
どうしても出ないのか考えてくださいその時にあなたは上司の漫画ですね
う側は何かそれで自分の立場を使ってその例において何かを獲得しようとしてないのか
を一つ文と思って考えてほしいですね
考えて考えて考えて欲しいですもし真実の愛をやるにあたって何か講ずるしようって
いう気持ちがあるんであれば1回止まった方がいいと
ん
二つ目の同意できない状況ですね例えばのも遠いができない状況は意識がはっきりして
いない時です
そりゃそうですよね2人でしたいしたい
はいやりたいですはいしたいレスっていうのが遠いなわけですから
その積極的なしたいという気持ちが持ちようがないですよね式がないんだったら
なので
お酒をたくさん飲んでいたり薬物を服用していたりとかして石はっきりしていない人は
遠いができません
なのでお酒をたくさん飲んでいる人と性行為することは遠いがない
つまり暴力です
3つ目の同意できない状況は強制された状況です
少し性行為から離れてみましょうもしあなたが銃を向けられた状態で財布を出して
くれるって聞かれたらどうぞを出します
出しますよねお金味噌は時にお金をあげることに同意したって言いますか
言わない
ねこれ強盗に遭ったって言うんですけどなので仕事上とか
学問上の不利益な取り扱い明示した上での性的な関係とか
俺をしないとどうするとっていう風な脅迫がある関係の中ではどうができません
これぐらい皆さん当然なのかなというふうに思っております
4つめ同意できない状況は十分な情報が与えられていなかったり騙されている状況です
例えば御楼門してのセックスに同意したりもわからず実はしていなかったり
それはまさに騙されている状況ですよねそれがどういうがしようがないので
性豪力にあたります
あるいは撮影していることを知らされていなかったりとか自分が何らかの性病を持って
いたりとかそういうことを知っているのにも関わらず告げずに性的な関係を持った場合
これもある特定の状況での成功に同意することができませんので同意できない状況です
のでおいできます
異論の同意できない状況から遠いができるためにどんな状況があればいいのか分かり
ます
一つ目これは必須条件です対等な関係であること
二つ目意識がはっきりしていること
3つ目強制されていないこと4つ目
情報が十分与えられていること
これグッズです
これで漏えいについて少しずつわかってきましたでも同意のない性的言動はすべて性
暴力という風に言うとじゃあ
ハッキリ no って言わなかった方が悪いんでしょ
自分は相手がどういってると思った同意してない人に性的な関係を共有することを自分
は悪い人じゃないんだと思う
いらし
いるかもしれませんそれは違います
ごめんなさい違うんです遠いにはもう一つ重要なルールがあります
その重要なルールとは
同意を取る責任はアクションを起こす側にあるということです
これは男性とか女性とかそういうことなんですねアクションを起こす側に同意を取る
責任がある
性的なことをしたいと思って最初に行動を起こす側が相手が同意しているかを確認する
必要があるんです
はっきり言わなかった方が悪いのではありません
ちゃんと確認しなかった方が悪いのです同意できない状況のように相手が上司であっ
たりだとか
あるいはお互いに知り合ったばかりであ
ての気分を悪くしたくないなぁとかあるいはですね付き合っていて好きなんだけど空い
てる
今日はそういう気分じゃないでも枚がれたら困る
突破ですねだからもうはっきり言うというのはとても難しいことがあります
なので人はなんとな断りたいときに
曖昧な態度になりますだからノーと言わない方は悪くないんです
やって断りにくい状況だからなので
イエスとはっきり言わない時はアクションを起こした側はこれは no だったんだな
というふうに受け取って今日のところは解散しましょう
もちろんね何かこう読み取れる具体的な文脈があればいいんですけど動くそういうわけ
にいかないというときには解散するっていうのが一番一番ですってを傷つけないことが
何より大切ですか
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
えさラーにもう1つ重要なことをつけたさせてください
それは付き合っていることや学校に性的な関係を持ったことがあることは性的言動に
ついてに通していることなんことです
たとえばある日一度性的な昆布につに同意したことは未来永劫に同意したことにはなり
ません
わかりますよね例えば今アイス食べたいっていう地味いったとするじゃないですかと
言う時に明日た額とは限らないですね
1週間後とかに当然てだんだんなんてあなたは一週間前にアイス食べたいって言ってた
よねほらクエオンカーンってやったらモス暴力だってことは多分
わかると思うんですよなので一回何かに同意した
決してその先ずーっと一度もそうしていいっていうことにはならないんですね
なので人も気分は変わるものですアイスを食べたい日もあれば食べたくない日もある
裏わかりますねなので一回一回隔離を取るということが大切です
さてこれでどういう取るのに必要な条件が
で揃えました一つ目対等な関係であること
二つ目意識がはっきりしていること
を見つめ矯正がないこと4つ目
十分な情報が与えられていること5つめ
報道起こす側が積極的なイエスを聞く必要がある
s 大きく責任があるということですそして6つ目が一回一回確認すること
同意のない性的な言動はすべて性暴力である
そして動揺するためには以上の6つが守られる必要がある
これが私が提案する性に関する新しい常識です
この話をするとですね絶対いるんですがめんどくさいと必ずじゃあ11契約書をかけて
言うのかっていう方
がいらっしゃいますそういう人に私はどうぞ書いてくださいと言っています
other も堅苦しく6つの条件という形で言いましたが人と人との
コミュニケーションの基本なんですね騙さないとか尊重しているとか権力関係の差が
あるときには踏み込みすぎないとかそういうことに対して何かこう反感を抱くっていう
か
とは1回考えた方が良いと思います自分のコミュニケーションのあり方について
特にその性的な関係を持つということはかなり親密な関係になることですよねやっぱり
コミュニケーションの中で
もう
基本的なことを守れない人と親密な関係になるっていうのは結構厳しいことだと思うの
で
契約書を書かないとわからないような人と性的なことをしないほうがオススメですあの
する的はいませんし
すべてそういうようなことができない人は逮捕されるとかそういうことが言いたいわけ
じゃないんですけど
基本
的にはベターだと思いますし自分が誰かを傷つけたくないと思うのであれば不結構簡単
に守れることなんじゃないかなというふうに思っています
じゃあその当然等簡単なことなんであんたワード話しているのと思う方もいらっしゃる
かもしれませんそれはですね
誤った常識のために傷ついたり相手を傷つけてしまったりとか
そういう人は自分の割にとても多かったからです
私がちゃんと家だと言わなかったから悪いのかもしれない
だからからし無理やりやるべてやだったけど
でも自分も悪いかもしれないって思ってしまった人あれは会社が仕方ないかって諦めて
しまったした
ノリが悪いって言われたら困ると思ってサークルね嫌だったけど
性的なことを向けられても笑っていた人
そういう話を聞いてですねすごい思ったんですよもう私もそうだかなと思いました
いやなのに声を出せなかったことをたくさんあります
そういう状況の中で私が初めて静的遠いという考え方に触れた時もやがパーッと晴れた
ような境地になったんですねも何となく嫌だと思っていた性的なからかいや接触冗談
でもそれは突然見知らぬ誰かに夜道でレイプされるわけじゃないんだから
明日ことじゃないんだって思う言っていました
もう遠いという言葉を知ってあれはせ暴力だったんだあれは56だったんだ私はいい
やって思って当然だったんだっていうふうに思たんですね
だから私はちゃんとを超えるようになりましたしまた似たような悩みを持つ友人たちに
それを暴力だよ
色つらかったねって言ってあげられるようになりましたまた
大したことないよって性的な非常になったしてに対して大したことないっていうことは
セカンドレイプという風に言うんですが遠いという考え方を知っていればですね
セカンドレイプをするって
確率も低くなるんじゃないかなとそれはだからあまり自分のパートナーとなる人を盗聴
することにもなるし自分の友人を尊重することにもなるし自分を守ることにもなるそれ
が遠いという考え
大切なことはそれがコミュニケーションをとる事ですそして相手を尊重することです
相手を大切に自分の気持ちで自分の体を大切にするためにチェーンと声に出してお互い
の気持ちを確認するそれは同意です
私たちはエスパーではありません言葉に出して話さなけれ
ば分からないことがたくさんあります
なのでもうしつつ最後にもう1回だけ確認させてください
いっ
同意のない性的な言動はすべて性暴力である
これを覚えて帰ってくださいもう誰も傷つかないためにもう誰も傷つけないために
静聴ありがとうございました